[Music]
hello there well you're watching the
press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive in the
next half an hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with journalist and
author christina patterson and deputy
political editor of the daily mail john
stevens very good evening to you both so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages well the sunday telegraph reports
that the prime minister is declaring war
on petrol stations that failed to meet
the government's fuel duty cut
the observer quotes mp saying there is
an identity crisis in the conservative
party as a result of partygate and
u-turns
the sunday times has a claim that
downing street figures lobbied sue gray
to dilute her report on the parties and
anonymize some of those involved
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on your screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight just remind you
by christina patterson and john stevens
so uh let's kick off then with this uh
on the front of the observer john you
pick it up johnson apparently is
trashing tory identity who's saying
that yes this is one of the problems
that you get when the prime minister's
in a tricky position is suddenly his
back benches have a lot of power
and start pulling them in different
directions and these are quotes from
syrian duncan smith who's obviously a
former tory leader himself and he's
complaining about the party's policies
on tax and says that they've got an
audited entity crisis when it comes to
tax because usually in the past the toys
have gone into election after elections
saying lay we're gonna put up your taxes
we will keep them low whereas what we've
seen in the last couple of months is
national insurance go up under the
tories which was a breach of the tory
manifesto from 2019 and so i think
you're going to see a lot of this from
people on the tour about benches over
the next couple of months saying if
you're going to stay in power boys
johnson this is exactly what i want you
to do
and christina i mean it seems that the
criticism of mr johnson is not coming
from just one quarter within the party
from all over the place
yes well i have to say i find it quite
funny that they call it an identity
crisis i mean i think the crisis is
rather bigger than that we have a
pathological liar at downing street who
has been partying and breaking the laws
that he set for the country throughout
the whole pandemic so you know it's not
really an identity crisis i think that
the way that most of us are looking at
it but yes and i think the reason that
tory mps are finally speaking out
against boris johnson is because they
are now getting the whiff of losing
their seats and i have to say it's
extremely unseemly that what encourages
them to speak out it has been evident
for a long long time
the partygate scandal has been
rumbling on for months it's been evident
what's been going on in downing street
it was clear to many of us years ago
that boris johnson was a pathological
liar but the fact that they can see now
that his popularity is waning that about
60 of the public think he should resign
over partygate and that taxes are going
up to record levels or record levels for
many years combined with the cost of
living crisis i think they they they now
think they're going to lose their jobs
and that is the thing that's causing
them to act and it's a disgraceful
reason to act well let's talk more about
uh party gate front of the sunday times
john gray diluted parties report after
pressure this is a an extraordinary
story about the amount of influence that
various people within downing street
tried to put
on sue gray to alter it
yeah we know that ahead of the report
being published different chunks went to
different people if they were named so
they could come back with the right
reply they had until last sunday
afternoon to say to sue gray whether
they had some excuse or any reason why
they didn't want to be named in the
report and we think that she contacted
about 30 people saying that she was
going to name them when actually we got
the report on wednesday there were only
15 names in there and one of the
allegations in the sunday times is that
different bits were taken out so the
party the night that dominic cummings
left downing street we know there's
allegations that there was a party that
took place in boris johnson's flat with
the claim was that there was abba music
blasting out the windows that everyone
could hear it downstairs and that's one
of the details that didn't appear in the
report this claims that in the draft it
said there was music playing and in the
actual report there wasn't music playing
and i think the tricky thing for boris
johnson is he obviously hoped that
they'd be able to get this report out
there and then move on and we're still
seeing stories about it days later and i
guess the big thing that they would
really be worried about is the
possibility that this draft report
before it was watered down somehow gets
leaked in the next few weeks john i mean
do you think that it is going to
continue to dog the prime minister i
mean the feeling was particularly with
that big giveaway by rishi sunak on
thursday that you know they had got away
with it and they were going to move on
you think there is still plenty more
damage to be done
i think if you look at the last few days
in the immediate aftermath of that
report coming out it seemed like the
tory back benches were silent but i
think that was more that people were
reserving judgment rather than they were
all absolutely in support of boris
johnson and what you've seen since then
has been a slow trickle of mps coming
out and one of the things in the sunday
times story is talking about is
parliament's in our recess so we won't
have the commons for the next week but
there are people on the tory side who
are worried that we might end up with
the 54 letters going in which you'd need
no confidence vote in the prime minister
and one of the reasons they think
there's a real possibility of that is
because the rebels aren't organized it's
all different people who are unhappy for
loads of different reasons and i think
we could end up getting to that 54 by
accident okay and uh christina we
mentioned that their sunax big giveaway
on thursday now there was one before
that not quite so big but in it was a 5p
cut in petrol duty which didn't seem to
get passed on we got this on the front
of the telegraph pm's war on rip-off
petrol stations he wants it passed on in
full what's he going to do about it
he's going to do he's going to fulminate
in a way that makes a telegraph front
page so that they can
give the impression that uh boris
johnson is acting on behalf of the
british people because all the other
news surrounding boris johnson is
incredibly bad and from the telegraph's
point of view that the windfall tax
which of course richard sunak claimed
isn't a windfall tax is also bad news
because it's a tax and uh that gets back
to the identity issue that the tories uh
party which is meant to be the party of
low taxation has become a party of high
taxation i think what we're seeing is a
is a prime minister who's flailing
around actually desperate to come up
with kind of tiny bits of of you know
kind of
dead cats basically things that will
take people's mind off partygate but as
john said it's not going to go away and
thank you by the way john for your
invitation to somebody to leak the the
draft report the draft sue grey report
because we clearly do need to read it
and i have to say as the daughter of a
civil servant who would be turning his
grave now about the way that simon case
and martin reynolds and some of these
other civil servants have behaved i am
absolutely horror struck at the way the
civil service has been infected by the
corruption and law breaking and lies
that have apparently determined the new
culture at number 10 i think the fact
that civil servants actively tried to
censor a report that was meant to be an
independent report by another civil
servant is absolutely disgraceful sure
plenty of them not happy about it
they're just noticing of these there's
kind of two stories on the sunday
telegraph that that join up we've got
this uh war on ripoff petrol stations
that's about passing on the fuel duty
but presumably the prime minister john
wants some them to start selling petrol
in gallons again because there's another
story there about pounds and ounces
being bought back
yeah this is a story that the government
in the coming days is going to set out
propose legislation for
repealing laws that came into law when
we were members of the eu which means
that you can't sell um goods in imperial
measurements i
mean i can see i mean i'm the wrong
person to discuss this story because i
literally have no memory of any of these
things i just don't think there's gonna
be that shots in a rush to bring back
imperial measurements but obviously if
you grow up with them then fine i'm sure
a lot of people be excited but i'm not
sure it's going to be a big change on
the way
that is the issue listen stay with us
we're going to take a break uh because
the sunday times reports the police
chiefs are at war over a race to lead
the national crime agency which has
become embroidered in cronyism claims
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now our journalist and
author christina patterson and deputy
political editor with the daily mail
john stevens right i want to pick up on
this story also on the front of the
observer christina about
ukraine please for arms as key allies
falter well there does seem to be
perhaps signs of a split in the support
for ukraine tell us about that and the
need of course for some long-range
weaponry
yes well it's so it's a very very
worrying moment in the war obviously the
whole thing is incredibly worrying last
night in fact we um our friends have
taken in a ukrainian mother and her
child and it brought it very close to
home
um just what people have been living
through but essentially uh putin is
destroying the whole of eastern ukraine
and it looks as if he is kind of winning
that in in that part of ukraine if you
can call destroying uh raising an entire
area to the ground winning and what's
happened is that uh france and germany
have been trying to persuade putin to
negotiate um and we are being very gung
ho liz trust has repeatedly called for
uh ukraine to not surrender even any
land that um it had already lost by 2014
like crimea i mean basically liz trust
is more gung-ho than the ukrainians
which is a little bit alarming i don't
think we should be asking for things
ukrainians are not asking for but i
think there is a split now and i think
it's very very difficult for anyone to
know if you are dealing with somebody
like putin who may or may not be mad but
is clearly extremely determined to do
whatever it takes to get some kind of
victory in ukraine at a terrible price
it's very hard to know what approach to
take and i think we should be giving
more weapons to ukraine but the fear is
that long-range weapons might be used in
russia which of course uh took targeted
to russian territory which could of
course cause it could of course cause a
major escalation in the war and involve
nato so it's very very frightening
territory and hard to know what the
right thing is to do
indeed let's get back to domestic issues
john this also on the front page of the
sunday times an extraordinary route
taking place
amongst the top brass as they put it
involving the police this is over the
the role to lead the national crime
agency and it's between neil basu and uh
lord hogan howe tell us what's going on
yes so one of the things that has wound
people up is there are claims that boris
johnson has demanded that lord hogan how
who is an ally of his who used to run
the met i think when he was london mayor
he's demanded that he's been considered
for this new top job as head of the nca
and this is pert people's knows that
joint they say that when he was head of
the met that he mucked up the
investigation into
the vip pedophiles remember when they
looked at whether politicians had been
involved in
child grooming gangs
and so these are some quotes from neil
basu who is currently assistant
commissioner at the metropolitan police
he's the most senior non-white police
officer in the country he was in the
running it seems he's been told he's no
longer in the running and he is
demanding an explanation for why he's no
longer being considered for this job
uh another domestic story on the front
of the telegraph christina and this i
suppose goes along so many things seem
to be grinding to a halt as the
telegraph puts it um we've got past
sports haven't we now it's driving tests
uh learners face being unable to book a
test until
2023 because of a
crisis at the dbsa
yes this is um i mean as you say
everything seems to be passports are a
complete nightmare masses of people are
unable to go on holiday because they
can't get their passports in time and
now
people aren't able to get driving tests
for many many weeks and and there is a
talk in some cities that there won't be
any slots available until the end of the
year or even
next year um interestingly the
government has said that nobody should
be waiting more than 14 weeks but then
failed to come up with any numbers to
back this up which seems to be a rather
consistent government line i must say if
you're 17 and raring to pass your
driving test then it's it it's you know
it's tough i remember i passed my
driving test uh a week before my 18th
birthday and then promptly crashed the
car as soon as i passed it which was the
kind of
a kind of sanitary lesson in
you know using a bit of caution and
driving but no it's i mean i don't know
what exactly what's causing all these
delays but uh it's it's really not good
and um i don't see why why they're so
hard to solve yeah we're here
talking people scouring the united
kingdom for places where there isn't
such a cue and being prepared to travel
many many miles to take their tests john
i think we'll squeeze the last one in
lovely story front of the observer a
picture of the finishing touches of
soldiers on parade in london for the
jubilee of course
yeah this is everyone getting ready for
the end of the week the long bank
holiday i think most people are off work
thursday and friday
and this is soldiers rehearsing for
trooping the color which will take place
on thursday there's that picture one of
the front pages they've got a picture of
prince william with his bare skin hat
and appears to be um setting off some
sort of allergy looks like he's slightly
uncomfortable but yeah i think a lot of
people are looking forward to the end of
week and
celebrating a truly magnificent woman